(fun dance music)
- I think Japanese pop music will sound
really fast, really happy.
- Like electronic music
with high-pitched voices.
- It'll probably sound like Katy Perry.
- Like Bjork.
- Da-Ice, sounds like a 90's rap group.
- Whoa, this is fast.
- Oh, it's really happy, it's really fun.
- It's kind of like a Goofy movie.
- I just imagine a bunch of people
on a dance floor just sweating.
- This is some (bleep)
you could work out to
and just kill it on the treadmill.
- It definitely sounds like
an American country song.
But like more bells and
(bleep) in the background.
- Beautiful symphony in the background,
some piano, it's got everything.
It's pulling out all
the stops, for romance.
- This sounds like John Denver.
- He's really sad about it,
maybe he's asking his dad for a loan.
- This is like you're
coming down on some drugs
and your ass is done.
- It really sounds a
lot like Sesame Street.
- I could picture myself
crying to this song.
- I'm on a game show, running
down the stairs to this song.
- That is so high-pitched.
- This song feels like it's
a commercial for liquid soap.
- This is exactly like
Rainbow Road on Mario Kart.
- These are like sorority girls,
sitting around talking
(bleep) about someone,
being real sassy.
- It's probably about friendship,
it's probably about honesty.
- A 14 year-old girl
that's like trying to get
out of the house and get away
from her oppressive parents.
And she's like pleading with them,
but they're like "You're 14
and you sound like a mouse,
"so we don't trust you."
- Japanese pop music is delightful.
- It's very upbeat and it's very fast
and it's very in-your-face.
- It's like you're
inside the circuit board
of a new computer.
- Every song is like a hug.
They're so positive, they're so friendly.
It's like a handshake and
a wink and a milkshake.
It's everything you want in music.
(fun dance music)